welcome to simply learn Python versus R
versus SAS my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that is w W
simply learn comm get certified get
ahead in our Python vs. R vs SAS we're
going to cover today a little bit of the
history we're gonna go into the cost the
speed the ease of learning data handling
data visualization and graphical
analysis deep learning support usage and
Industry these last parts are all about
job search customer and community
support job trends popularity preference
by industry so let's take a look at
where this came from in Python it's an
object-oriented programming language
that is primarily used for software
development and web development and data
science so we look at the history of
Python originally wasn't for data
analysis and data analytics it was
originally a full-blown software package
and still is today used widely in all
kinds of different software development
web development and data science R is
majorly used by statistical analysis
data mining and machine learning so it
was designed just for doing data
analysis and SAS is a statistical
software suite widely used for business
intelligence
you might hear that as bi for business
intelligence data management and
predictive analysis and like r is
designed specifically for your data
science so we look at the history Python
was created by Giovanni Rossum in 1990
as a successor to ABC language and it
was named after the British TV show
Monty Python and his written in C so our
back end is a C code and I always like
the fact it was my knee python that it
came from and Flying Circus and life
according to Bryant and all the fun ones
and then R was created by Ross he Hakka
and Robert gentlemen as an
implementation of the S programming
language named after the first names of
the two are Arthur's and written in C
Fortran and R so when they put this
together they put together all kinds of
different tools pulling it all together
and so you see both Fortran and C is a
back-end and then we have SAS
was developed at North Carolina State
University and that was done from 1966
to 1976 by Anthony J bar it's written in
the seat language has started as a
project to analyze agricultural data and
increase crop yield and this is
interesting because Python came up in
the early nineteen what 1994 so and so
there are that came about the same time
but R was just data science where Python
came started up as a programming
language and so we talked about the
initial release of Python it came out in
1994 followed by version 2 a Python in
2000 and in 2008 Python version 3 was
released the recent release of Python is
three point seven point four although
they just came out with the beta on the
three point eight and that's now come
out it's coming out as a stable version
here in 2019 R has its initial version
released in 1995 so there's our 1994 for
Python a year older than R but keep in
mind that our was right off the bat for
data science Python was not it was a
general programming language and had a
stable version and R had a stable beta
version in 2000 our version 2.0 came out
in 2004 followed by versions 3.0 in 2013
version 3 point 6 point 1 is the recent
release and SAS had mini releases since
1972
now after 50 years almost 50 years
that's a long time since the release of
version 93 SAS stat has its own release
numbering so we look at cost of course
if you're a business investing in these
different software's it's important to
understand the cost and the benefit
Python is an open-source programming
language which is completely free so
it's used by anybody who needs it or
wants to download it you could download
it now for free of cost no charge r is
also open source which can be downloaded
and used by individuals and
organizations so it too is a free
language available for anybody who wants
to download and use it SAS on the other
hand is a proprietary software and
companies need to pay a considerable
amount to use it SAS has also introduced
a free university edition so they do
have a limited edition you can use for
doing Studies and coursework so when we
look at the speed and we'll come back to
the cost and why you'd want to invest in
SAS and some of its benefits but we go
on we want
the speed Python being a high-level
programming language is faster for
building large applications and web
development this makes sense because you
can actually replace your ask your PHP
all of your Java back-end Enterprise
that goes on the server you can actually
do that in Python and have it directly
put out the webpages so if we're doing
web development is probably one of the
fastest combinations of data science and
web output are is a low-level
programming language so you need more
extended codes for simple procedures
which results in reduced speed now when
I say simple procedures I'm talking
about the coding side of it are is very
fast for doing very basic statistical
analysis and getting in your basic set
up in basic graphs and then SAS SAS
enables better data analysis using SAS
sequel and automatic code generation
with reusable code snippets so it's a
little bit quicker to develop and they
also sit on their own back-end
processing setup which is also quite
fast and we talk about ease of learning
Python is a scripting language that
provides easy and simple syntax with the
analytics friendly libraries it has
become a phenomenon and the data
analytics and this is just really cool
cuz there's so many modules out there
that is probably the hardest part about
learning Python is all the modules and
the learning it is just really hard to
track them all R has a little bit of
that problem too Mar also has a steep
learning curve because it is a low-level
language and needs working knowledge of
coding and again I'll supplement that
that R itself when you're doing certain
tasks in are they're actually easier
than other programming languages when
you do your first analysis and then SAS
SAS is supposed to be the easiest to
learn among the three and has a simple
GUI or general user interface it can be
picked up by anyone without a prior
programming language this is a huge
benefit and if you remember correctly we
talked about SAS being a paid-for
product this is one of the reasons
people pay for it because the manager
can go in there or a team leader who
might not know a lot about data science
and still use it and do a lot of basic
things in there that the data sciences
do also so they can follow it and work
with them and then we talk about data
handling Python has popular libraries
such as numpy and pandas for data
analysis and manipulation which may
data handling and python easier and
numpy is just you look at it as a giant
array so it's very fast and it's always
increasing their speed and how they can
maximize that speed that's why not be so
popular then panda is your data sheet if
you ever work with big data like spark
you're always talking about the data
sheet that data frame you're looking at
something that's almost like an Excel
spreadsheet and then R has a
disadvantage as it works only on RAM and
small tasks will take time to run but
data manipulation is easier with the
packages like p ly r and d p liar and
toi dy r so these different packages
just like modules in python you do
everything in modules in python with are
you start finding there's all these
packages have been slowly added in that
makes it more more compatible and easier
to use
the fact that the basic are loaded into
Ram makes it different difficult to work
with very large data sets
this is not completely true as we talk
about big data there's a whole nother
state set up on there and you can
actually work R with what's called h2o R
and then SAS can perform efficient data
handling and manipulation using the data
step which compiles and runs faster and
this is their own back-end this is all
in-house proprietary ship for their data
step which really helps the efficiency
and data handling that said both R and
Python are open source and we see huge
jumps and how fast it can process the
data and how good it is at pulling data
and data handling and then we talk about
data visualization and graphical
analysis this is huge in data science to
be honest if you can't display your data
and your results in a way that anybody
can understand it if you can't take it
to the head of the sales team and the
head of the marketing and the CEO of the
company and say here this is what it
looks like and give them a visual you're
in trouble it's got to look good and you
got to put out something fast and easy
and quickly spin up your own setup on
there and show them what's going on now
Python has packages like mat plot
library Seaborn and Visby that make it
powerful for data visualization and
graphical analysis and I'm going to come
back a little bit and talk about Python
in comparison as we look into our and
into sass our winds among the three for
data visualization analysis with
packages like ggplot lattice Gigi vis
and our GIS it's
what I like about our is I can so
quickly pump the results out and put it
into an easy to see graph that I can
print out and show somebody which makes
it really just for initial data analysis
the winner of all three of these now we
talk about Python Python and they so
Seaborn and Matt plot library visit I
they have so many packages that you can
do a lot of what you can do and are you
can do even more and one of the things
about visualization in Python is that
you can spin up some of the coolest
graphs and things like that but you it's
a high learning curve it takes a lot to
go in there and figure out how to do it
say in Matt plot library Seabourn sits
on top I'm at plight library and
automate some of that and has some new
features and you can do all the things
you do in R and you can actually do a
lot more and your plotting and in your
graphing and then we talk about sass
sass has been working to improve its
visualization and graphical capabilities
but is yet to match the standards of
Python and our one of the nice things
about sass is it does a lot of things
automatic but it's very limited in what
you can do so that's the downside of
sass where R can do some fairly
complicated graphs right out of the box
easy to setup and then if you're willing
to go in and dig into all these
different modules and figure out which
one does what Python can do
significantly more and publish it out
into the web and has all kinds of
additional features so you can see that
these three different packages have very
different data visualization they're in
different places as far as the
visualization and graphical analysis now
a lot of people will work in R and do
some very basic stuff in R and put out
some basic graphs and then they'll do
the actual project in Python or SAS just
because R can get you right out the door
just so amazingly fast you can do a lot
of cool things in our with very little
work so we talked about deep learning
this is your neural networks right now
the two big neural networks are out
there our tensorflow and cross python
has had major developments in the fields
of deep learning with libraries such as
tensor flow and cross and it's being
used by data scientists and it has the
SK learned has a deep learning package
it has so many different options for
neural networks now and it is a leading
choice as far as a number of different
neural networks that plug in to it so we
talked about our are added packages like
cross
that acts as an interface to the
original Python packages cross it has
other packages like MX net are h2o for
deep learning and I mentioned the h2o
earlier the h2o is really the package
that's puts it over multiple computers
that's your big data so now lets you use
multiple processors more efficiently and
that actually sits on the same Hadoop
SPARC framework so your hto usually uses
what's called yarn yet another resource
negotiator which is an integrated part
of Hadoop and spark and then SAS SAS is
working to improve his deep learning
support with open source packages like
DLP Y cafe models and building its own
deep learning toolkit so if you're
working in neural networks and deep
learning SAS is a couple steps behind
but given how quickly these things
develop don't be surprised if it shows
up tomorrow on the SAS and it's
up-to-date with everybody else and then
go one more step in here before we leave
the whole our SAS and deep learning and
start looking at the industries and
where this is being used something to
note is that there is a whole
development and process that's starting
to release our modules that function in
Python so we're starting to see a
crossover people in Python are realizing
if they're using the R as their basis
why not build it into the Python package
and then you can have it all in one
setup so let's go ahead and jump into
usage and industry and this is last part
this discussion today this is of course
looking for jobs where you gonna go what
are you gonna do or if you're looking to
see if your business or corporation
sometimes it's good to use the same
packages that everybody else is using in
that industry the reason being that if
they're developing their tools some of
those tools get published and you start
seeing those in the help boards and so
much more comes out that it makes it a
lot easier to dive in and get your job
done
Python is used in organizations to build
web apps analyze data automate
operations via DevOps and build machine
learning and deep learning models now
keep in mind Python is probably the most
widely used of these three as far as a
diverse program and it is a full
programming language our R is majorly
used for statistical analysis data
mining data visualization and machine
learning it is used in every field
finance bioscience manufacturing supply
chain and you really see that you know
back in the nine
finance and bioscience and he's huge
research and development going on in
these different companies went to our
because back in the 90s our was the only
really solid thing out there our SAS
those were your two choices then pythons
started building their modules coming up
and so a Python stepped in and it's only
been in the last 10 years that Python
has really taken off as a data science
tool and SAS has found vast uses in the
pharmaceutical industry for analyzing
patient records creating safe drugs and
clinical research it is also used for
weather forecasting and business
intelligence well there's that bi
business intelligence SAS probably is
really widely used in the business
intelligence field that's one of the
main areas you'll see it in there but
it's used across all of these industries
and we'll go and take a closer look at
some of the graphs showing where these
different tools are being used customer
and community support now this is
important before we dive into the graphs
since Python is free it doesn't have any
customer support but it has a huge
online community support to raise your
issues you can go into google and type
in Python and what you're looking for
Python tensorflow and you'll just see
tons of different support pages coming
up forums all kind of places where
people have posted information on Python
and whatever module you're looking into
or whatever you're trying to do that's
also a downside because you have to dig
through all those postings to find the
one that is what you're looking for are
also does not provide customer support
and it too has a large online community
support to solve your queries so you can
go in and look and say hey how do I do
this in our and just pull that right up
and usually you can get the answer
rather quickly off the forums
now SAS because it's a paid-for service
has 24/7 customer support to assist you
as well as an online community to help
solve your doubts that's pretty powerful
if you're in a large business so what I
see in start-up businesses are business
starting now if it's a large company and
they already have SAS in some of their
other areas they'll go with the support
because you usually have the money to
fund it startups on the other hand will
almost always go for the Python and the
are a lot of times they'll utilize both
of those in their back-end development
and in their R&D so what's like a job
trends Python has a huge demand with
as companies looking for resources who
know Python so the job openings for
Python is very high this is expected to
increase in the future and you can see
this is actually a generic graph in
there it's not the actual data but this
is a trend it's just shooting straight
up it's a heavy growth in python r is
also very high demand in the field of
statistics and data analysis companies
are looking for professionals who can
handle their data efficiently now python
is taking off faster than r but that is
because it's widely used in other uses
and in addition to data science because
it is a full programming language but
both are on path on just by the nature
of the fact that data science is taking
off are probably two of the fastest
growing tools in data science and in the
industry in SAS SAS is mostly used in
big organizations who can afford the
cost to buy the SAS software and it's
usage is limited so there are lesser
number of jobs and SAS as compared to
python and r and we're starting to see a
drop-off in SAS I would imagine that
given how fast data science is growing
that that drop-off will probably level
off just because there is such a big
demand in data science and then we look
at popularity we start looking at the
number of people using it and you can
see right here python is the most
popular and then r comes in a little bit
below and then right below that is SAS
this is again note the python is used
for a lot of other things instead of
just data science and I think that feeds
into that 41% you know so the actual
industry wise might be a little closer
it's kind of hard to tell and actually
pull these numbers out and get a full
view of them and we can dig a little bit
closer and actually look at by industry
you can see here telecommunication is
primarily Python you can see in
consulting kind of a share between
Python and our marketing marketing used
to be just SAS and then Python has
really come in and now it matches the
demand in marketing finance again SAS
used to be the top one in finance and
then Python over the last decade is
really shot up retail retail it's kind
of been across the board but you can see
that Python again is taken the industry
and then healthcare healthcare used to
be just SAS
and then our came in and python has come
up and now they're pretty much neck to
neck as part as far as a preference by
industry so as you start looking at
different jobs and trying to decide
which one you want to use or if your
company trying to figure out which one
it's going to be your best tool it's
kind of good to look at all the
different aspects and cost and what's
that going to mean to your team do you
need the 24/7 support are you gonna want
something that your manager can get in
and use quite easily in SAS or do you
want to have them where they they're
gonna have to start building more tools
and do those presentations a little bit
more which is your R and Python so we'll
go ahead and wrap that up thank you for
joining us today we covered a lot of
information today as far as the
difference between Python R and SAS if
you have any questions feel free to post
them down below in the YouTube comments
and please join our youtube subscription
we have many other different
publications we put out that you might
find useful again thank you for joining
us this is w w simply learn comm get
certified get ahead hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here